puis d'emprunter du centre est ce que je
préfère mon pays à toute autre
considération la réponse est oui le
président macron a été élu est il donc
légitime moi je souhaite la réussite de
mon pays qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement arrivée à l'assemblée
nationale si les habitants de boulogne
me font confiance je porterai toujours
les valeurs qui sont les miennes dans
quel groupe
je suis républicain je n'ai pas brevets
doivent être publiques 1 a donné je suis
l'organisateur des primaires de ma
famille politique
la seule chose qui m'importe encore une
fois c'est qu'on ne soit pas ce qu'on
est trop souvent gauche et droite depuis
quarante ans dans notre pays dans des
postures politiques moi j'en ai entendu
des députés de droite quand on était
dans l'opposition qui disait quand on
est dans l'opposition on s'oppose
même si le texte est bon et d'écouter ça
c'est fini parce que je considère que la
situation de notre pays nous impose de
prendre nos responsabilités et donc à
l'averse de beaucoup je le dis à mes
électeurs dès aujourd'hui sur des sujets
économiques sur ce qui renforcera la
sécurité des français sur la fluidité du
marché du travail sur la baisse des
charges valeur des impôts voteriez les
ordonnances la réforme assure qu est ce
que vous pourriez voter d'autres dans le
programmes des manuels macron
éventuellement dans un groupe d'appui à
l'assemblée nationale toute mesure qui
donnera plus de sécurité plus de
compétitivité économique à notre pays et
plus de renforcement de l'état régalien
en dans le cadre donc d'un groupe
d'appui comme le dit déborah donc c'est
la question que l'on vous pose est-ce
que selon vous au lendemain des
législatives
la scission de votre parti l air est
inéluctable ou pas on a constitué
ils ont constitué agi adhéré dès sa
création l'ump à l'est républicain
aujourd'hui en demi de cela la présence
de jean-marie le pen au second tour de
la présidentielle c'était une stratégie
d'union de la droite et du centre dans
la même famille politique pour nous
permettre d'avoir une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale on sait ça ne m'a
pas échappé à personne je pense que la
droite et le centre ont été éliminés dès
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec la candidature de
françois fillon dont bien sûr qu'il ya
une crise importante alors l une des
renouveaux par tes biens sociaux une 6
juin moi je ne suis pas dans une logique
de ce site tout de suite de se scinder
ce que je cherchais à convaincre et à
discuter avec mes collègues en leur
disant on est un parti il fut du
gaullisme on est un parti pro-européen
on est un parti qui défend des valeurs
de liberté économique d'autant
telle est enroulée que l air et moi je
le veux donner leur voix dans d'autres
considérations
sinon c'est pas on est plus l air